how would you advise someone to go
through breaking up with a partner then
or how would should people work out if
they need to break up it's a difficult
question
a very difficult question and it's a and
the cop out answer is the true one which
is only you'll know
and but what is also true is sometimes
you don't know sometimes you're so
deluded in your relationship and you're
so scared of the other side because
you're so terrible at being alone that
you've got this thing of like even if
this is [ __ ] it's better than nothing
and that's never true by the way
like no relationship is always better
than a [ __ ] relationship like being
single isn't the easiest thing in the
entire world but it's objectively better
than like going to bed besides someone
who uses hope stops breathing in the
middle of the night
like just that disappointment every
[ __ ] morning when your alarm clock
goes off and you feel them move on the
other side and you go [ __ ] all right
another one of those days here he or she
is mrs [ __ ] breathed through her nose
all right grand another 24 hours in
[ __ ] hell is it no
like when you start feeling that way
it's probably time to because the reason
i broke up with my ex was because i wish
she was dead and that wasn't because she
deserved to die but i'm like man the
second i want you to die or the second i
don't want to give you all of myself you
deserve better as well man it's like
you've got to remember if you're in a
relationship you don't like the other
person you owe it to them not to waste
their [ __ ] time anymore like breakups
are always hard right we know there
because there's no perfect way to do
them i mean there were i don't know what
was wrong with texting but apparently we
all had a vote
and
texans just snarling i don't get i don't
get why it's just so efficient it's over
no way you don't need an expert come on
[ __ ] it's done who cares but all right
we had a vote and morally it's wrong i
see i got it
um
you know it's gonna suck from a long
time and every second you don't break up
with them it's like time within that
person and your own
you know healing
that you're robbing them from like i
think if you're not allowed to text them
what's the
what's the optimal way to try and get it
done because it's difficult you've got
this thing you want to do you're talking
to a person you're terrified of being on
your own you don't want to hurt them you
don't want to hurt yourself it's like a
it's the perfect cocktail to not make a
decision yes i and then there's also the
the anxiety and especially if you are in
a toxic relationship which is the ones i
encourage people to get out of you've
always got that fear in the back of your
head whether it's valid or not that the
other person is going to do harm to
themselves or others if they're in a
heightened saddened emotional state and
the
brutal truth of it is you are not
responsible for other people's feelings
and emotions and or their actions and
it's nice to feel it's don't give up
it's a nice thing to
feel that concern for other people
that's empathy don't lose that it's not
a matter of not being empathetic but
it's a matter of understanding where
your responsibility to somebody else
like like them keeping you in a
relationship because you're worried that
they'll hurt themselves that's not a
good situation uh to be in so i mean
make sure that when you do it that
they're not you've not isolated them
like don't don't go on holiday with them
and then be like hey
guess what it's [ __ ] over thanks hey
thanks for coming to where i live just
to let you know it's over day one i know
you fly back in a week but hopefully you
can get over it scotland's beautiful
have a walk like that's not a kind way
to do it do it a place where you know
they can get support afterwards
and where you can um
but yeah i mean do get out of it as soon
as you as you [ __ ] can like why why
waste a second it's oddly narcissistic
to think about the effect that you
breaking up with someone has on them
because people think it's empathy but
it's not it's narcissism it's the belief
that without me how could you go on i
mean i i'm i'm so fantastic i'm
obviously your entire world your life
before me was essentially just one big
warm-up routine awaiting my arrival now
the king or the queen is here and you're
just going to be this slobbering mess on
the floor this grey goo how are you ever
going to get a better deck than this i'd
kill myself too if i were you and i was
losing this i'd be gone that'd be the
end of me so yeah i mean that is what it
is
[ __ ] man what about people that
break up i think you talk about this in
the book people that want to break up
because they have the allure of novelty
of being single again and just wanting
to [ __ ] lots of people well i think
that's i mean i've always said the
number
what i believe the number one cause of
breakups and divorce later on in life is
curiosity which is like you know
um
this
let's let's
be true love is brilliant and it's what
we all should be looking for in life but
we should always looking for it in its
truest form just because we're so
desperate to find the real thing doesn't
mean we should buy a knockoff one on the
way or sell for a [ __ ] knockoff one
love is really really
uh
brilliant to expect in fact i've rambled
so much i've forgotten the questions go
again
they were talking about whether people
should break up because they want to
[ __ ] lots of different people oh well i
mean should is an interesting way to
phrase it but yeah like you do get if
you if you fall in love in high school
man when you've got no other
love to compare it to like you do and
you stay together all that time and you
have kids early on because that's part
of the plan there will be a point when
you're 30 or 40 and you've been with
this person for 15 years where you just
get curious and it's not in like i think
i'm going to do well but it's you just
don't know your friends aren't in
relationships one of them goes through a
divorce or you're just so used to this
is your new normal now that you know now
that your kids are teenagers you can
slow down a bit
and suddenly you're a different person
than you were several years ago of
course you are because you've gone
through this and also the person you're
with is a different person because
you've all gone through these changes
now hopefully you grow uh together and
sometimes you don't but you can still
learn to be with each other
during that but you
get this idea of like oh man if i was
single i'd be [ __ ] great at like oh
man i'd i'd i'd be this i've got this
and it's all a lie it's all this
illusion in our heads that you know
we i used to have a joke about it on
stage that i could never get working
which was like when you're in a
relationship and you picture being
single you're like a lion that's been
raised on a zoo like and it's just
you're behind the bars and you're
looking at all the human joint man if
these bars weren't here i get every one
of you i'm the [ __ ] king of savannah
i'd move you all [ __ ] down in reality
if you were to drop a caged lion who
grew up in a zoo in the savannah it
would be dead in three [ __ ] hours
it's never had to hunt for meat it had
zookeepers just bring it out like it
would die it would be it would be killed
by a [ __ ] gazelle
would just run into the side of it and
it wouldn't know what to do and it would
whimper and die like that's people in
relationship but i think they just took
that as a massive insult and they didn't
like the joke the grass is always
greener with this stuff man and i think
yeah so many people that are in
relationships that have been in them for
a very very long time
they don't know what single life is
actually like like i'm not talking about
the idealized top five percent of being
single the
excitement of speaking to someone and
not knowing if you're going to get it on
and then they're going back to the house
and the taxi ride where you're fumbling
around in the back on the way there and
being told by the taxi driver to stop
doing that you can't do that in here
mate and like that's that that bit fun
but the wake up the next day with the
hangover and the existential angst
the constant feelings of insufficiency
and insecurity about whether or not this
person does like you the [ __ ] time
the ta oh my the dear lord the amount of
time on whatsapp or on [ __ ] instagram
or whatever
yeah but and then all the loneliness as
well i mean like being single is a lot
of time and you have to if you've been
in a relationship for 15 years
[ __ ] you ain't good at being
alone i know it's alluring to you but go
on a fishing trip like you're not ready
for real alone like that's what you
that's why people get into relationships
is because they're so bad at being alone
the other one is the
is the is the safer option for them but
um
i i always think when people are do get
that curiosity of like i wish i was
single i'm like man understand though as
well on the other side you've got people
out here in the single game wishing
they'd been in relationships for 15
years wishing they had that emotional
connection with someone in that life
journey like it's all about
uh perspective and whatnot but it's also
why i feel very secure in my
relationship because
like i'm i'm very in love with my fiance
she's uh wonderful we've been together
for four and a bit uh years now but
before her i lived a life man
like i'm not i'm not getting curious
when i'm 45
like
i i did it it was it was fun uh it's not
me anymore but
um like i always wanted to settle down
and have kids like that was always part
of my uh plan i love children and i i i
just i've always wanted to be a dad but
i always knew
that you know that was the when you
start that chapter if you do it right
the goal is for that to be forever you
don't want to do it multiple times uh
best case scenario is it's hard for the
rest and to do that i had to make sure
that i wasn't going to be curious i had
to make sure that when i was 50 no part
of my brain was like i wonder what a
threesome is like i had to make sure i
knew dude i've got a friend who's big
into pick up artistry and i was talking
to him years ago about this and i was
like man like you
put in a lot of graft with women like an
unforgivable amount of time that you put
in he's like yeah dude my future wife
better thank me for all of this time and
effort i'm putting in i was like
please elaborate to me on how your
future wife should be so thankful that
you've sprayed it around for the last
decade of your life he's like well i
don't ever want to be walking down the
street with my misses and our two kids
and look at a brazilian girl and think i
want to know what it's like to [ __ ] a
brazilian girl i want to have done it i
want to have ticked off every single one
of the different sexual kinks that i've
got because closing those loops gives my
future wife the best opportunity for us
to make it work i'm like well that that
might also
the other way around man like i'm like
i'm glad my fiance lived a [ __ ] life
before me man like would be i find
jealousy one of the most insane things
in a relationship especially if it's
jealousy of your partner's previous
actions before you like i'm a big
believer in the second we get into a new
relationship if unless it's murder or
pedophilia you've got to forgive me for
everything i did before this second
because i didn't know you existed before
this like all of that don't get me wrong
is a fair representation of my character
and i will always you know you have to
stand by your actions even the bad ones
you and you admit why they were [ __ ]
wrong but like you know my fears i've i
write about it in the book and this was
when i wasn't with my
fiance i think i
uh wrote that i really hope she was out
there in the world sucking dick right
now because i want her to be
good at it and i want her to not be
curious when i when we're older together
of course i wanted her to live her
[ __ ] life every time she talks about
like you know we're very open in our
relationship it was about you know past
conquests and stuff and man i'm proud of
it because i wasn't there and it's nice
to know that like man i got like i got a
good one this is like finding out that
you killed a general like this is
like i
i took one of the goats out of the game
[ __ ] this is cool
man if you retire michael jordan come on
you gotta that's a badge what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you